thanks for tuning in to this special
edition of Google developers live today
we're featuring L'Amour freed from
Adafruit Industries in celebration of
computer science education week
hello everyone my name is Natalie
Villalobos and I will be your host for
this special edition of Google
developers live today our guest is
l'amour Freed's l'amour is a graduate of
MIT receiving her bachelor's of science
and electrical engineering and computer
science and a master's in engineering in
2005 she created her own company
Adafruit Industries which is based in
New York and they sell hackable
electronic kits in 2011 she was featured
on the cover of Wired magazine the first
female engineer ever actually and in
2013 Entrepreneur Magazine named her
entrepreneur of the year thanks for
joining us the more thanks Natalie I'm
glad to be here to meet live engineer
awesome so most people in life most
people might not know you as l'amour
some know you as Lady ADA can you tell
us a little bit more about how you
received that name uh yeah so when I
used to break into computers when I was
in high school you had a hacker handle
and my handle with lady Ada and I never
got caught so that's kind of good and
after you know I graduated from school
and I'm like well you know I should
probably get a job and and you know or
start a company or something I decided
to keep my handle so I still go by Lady
Ada and the good news is I've registered
it I'm like all these websites for so
long that like Lady ADA is it I can't
really change now
awesome so you've created the Adafruit
learning system and you've all start
your own company so I want to hear about
that too can you tell us a little bit
more though first about the Adafruit
learning system sure um one of the
things that I do here at Adafruit is I
do a lot of engineering law developing
but when people buy stuff from the
Adafruit store oftentimes an electrical
Janiero it's like they don't have a lot
of experience with engineering they're
just makers or hackers or people who
maybe do software and they're dabbling
and doing some hardware and so they may
need a little bit of help kind of
getting started in how to use these
electronic parts in their projects and
so what we did is we had this huge like
vast amount of documentation and we
wanted to do a really good job and
having that documentation be easily
he's defined we wanted to integrate
photos and videos and side-by-side and
the photo notes and all the things that
make documentation for electronics
really really good I mean a lot of times
for documentation for software it's just
screenshots and text and that's okay but
with hardware you really want to show
videos and wiring diagrams and so we
developed our own web application that
once on the Adafruit servers called the
learning system and it's kind of like
bootstrap II and what it does is it
allows us to do back-end design
integration with our store so that you
know for example if a tutorial uses a
microscope or an Arduino or Raspberry Pi
those will get automatically tied
together and so people can find the
tutorials really easily they can just go
through our shop and say well I've got
this component or this component what
projects could I build with it and the
learning C's will automatically guide
them through like what school project
they can make that's super awesome and
sounds really easy so you have some
wearable technology projects as well and
being at Google we love some wearable
technology projects like Google glass
can you tell us a little bit about your
favorite wearables project and how we
might get started with one sure I really
like wearables I've been doing wearables
for a really long time was that the
wearables group in the Media Lab many
many many years ago and we were working
on like strapping computers to our
bodies and stuff and that was kind of
fun although really big and kind of
clunky the cool thing is is that 10
years later microcontrollers electronics
and batteries are so much better and
smaller that instead of whether you
spend like two thousand dollars to build
your own like like strapped on computer
you can actually do a lot of electronics
or like less than 50 bucks we have the
Adafruit Gemma which is a little
microcontroller platform specifically
for low-cost wearables and it's like
eight dollars so for eight dollars in
the couple of LEDs you can actually
start making integrated sensors LEDs
projects people like modifying their
shoes and their bags because shoes and
bags have like really stiff sides just
really easy to attach electron to them
and also wear them everyday and like
it's kind of cool to have like funky
shoes or
handbag so one of my favorite projects
right now is we have the firewalker
sneakers which is reactive shoes that
light up when you walk or dance awesome
says nothing there's fighting fire
anything like that no they just look
like you are because when you walk the
red LEDs like flicker and they look like
little flames like they're coming out of
your feet so I wore them on Halloween
and they're they're totally awesome
we're seeing lots of people build them
because they're dancers or artists or
actors and they want to have something
kind of cool and fun on stage or during
performances that's really calm that's
awesome yeah I like the idea of how
every item that you own or wear could
potentially be a platform and so
literally your platform could be your
platform that's right
let's hope trees have lots of space on
them you can tons of electronics in
their batteries like some energy
scavenging too even maybe make some
local power supplies to actually make
that work yeah sure so so one other
question that I that I'm really
interested in so a lot of times where
we're carrying these devices and we're
maybe not thinking how we can build on
them or how we can create them ourselves
so there seems to be this disconnect
between building and consuming can you
tell us a you know how we might get more
connected with our devices by building
on them or kind of your general thoughts
on that kind of era or this era of our
lives sure I think that especially now
it's it's hard to buy electronics that
are hackable unless you're actually
looking for that you used to be able to
buy a Commodore 64 or an Apple two gs
nickimja schematics and it's like we
want to add that 40 column Lord here's
how you do it and you know there'd be
pile phones and comforts and even that
stuff doesn't appear on computers
anymore there's really not a lot of easy
ways to integrate electronics into stuff
like a tablet it's like it's just a slab
of glass basically cuz why I think stuff
like the Raspberry Pi and Arduino is
really great you can take the con
technologies that have become low cost
because of tablets and cell phones and
laptops but then build your own computer
or build your own cell phone or build
your own camera and by doing that you
actually learn a lot and you get to
customize it in ways that maybe the
companies that are selling you a $500
digital camera or a laptop or tablet can
think of
so a lot of people take these
technologies like Arduino and Raspberry
Pi and the sensors and combine them
together to make something custom or
cool or you know something that is their
own not just something that they bought
this for yeah even better than what you
can buy so with different different
people of different interests
cycling painting rowing I don't know a
whole bunch of different things so if I
were a kid and I had these interests
how might coding or picking up in a
electronic hackable kid how can i
implement those interests into these
particular types of practices or
methodologies um I think everyone's got
like bees that are really fun and
interesting one of the cool new hobbies
that I'm seeing that is getting that's
picking up a lot of stuff with
electronics is cosplay and costuming so
there's only people who love to make
costumes mean like costuming is like the
most fun thing everyone loves Halloween
everyone loves to dress up and we've got
all these cool LEDs and wearable
electronics that we can now add to our
costumes to make them light up or make
sounds or effects or like make you move
more like a robot so I'm seeing a lot of
people like add electronics and making
to whatever hobby they already have like
I know people who really like to cycle
and so they make their own cycling
computers or their own light painting
rigs that attach to a bicycle people who
like to walk climb will make their own
timers or you know like digital cameras
that you know they can attach themselves
and take time lapses while they're doing
stuff all the stuff is taking
off-the-shelf electronics combining it
with coding and engineering to make what
you do more fun you know I know kids who
skateboard and then they put LEDs on
their skateboards so when they do tricks
they get these really cool light of X
this is stuff that you can't even buy
you have to make it hmm so there's a lot
of different so when you think of a
programmer or maybe maybe not when you
think of a programmer but when some
people think of a programmer it's
someone who's sitting behind a computer
and maybe is just typing and not really
having a lot of fun maybe they
like hunched back and I don't know it's
not doesn't seem to be a very glamorous
image if you were to fill in a you know
Madlib a programmer is what um for
people who do electrons engineering a
programmer is really creative you know I
also used to do computer science nice to
sit behind a screen and type and write
code and Java and I hated it it was like
so boring and I'm just like compiling
and deploying and like linking libraries
sounds like this this sucks actually
with bored of doing computer science cuz
it's just like you're sitting in a room
all day and so that's why I got
intellectual engineering that's when
doing you take all the skills that you
may learn in computer science classes
and even build stuff with it eat it show
it off to your friends you get to be
really creative I mean you can always
like make really cool apps and games and
stuff with software but I really think
that I love just having physical stuff
that moves like robotics or like
painting or making your own computer
computers or your own sensors or
wearables all that stuff is a way to
take programming and just make it more
fun awesome this is it we have a huge
developer audience that's watching what
would you like to share with them right
now we have Computer Science Education
Week we're empowering everyone to learn
how to code through an hour of code
campaign with go code org you know how
might you activate or how can developers
get involved or or where should they
start first with their kids and getting
them involved in the electoral
engineering or computer science sure I
think that you know it's always great to
start with some basic tutorials and
stuff but after you get a little bit of
the hang of programming either with you
know basic or scratch or new JavaScript
or whatever pick up something like an
Arduino starter kit or a Raspberry Pi
and then try and integrating all that
stuff that you learned in software with
sensors like try to make LEDs blink for
when you press a button something
happens and make some music
a lot of people like to booby-trap their
rooms like that's a common project a lot
of kids do because they have their own
space and you want to like modify it so
they'll put PIR sensors that can detect
people and magnetics
serves I can detect movement and then
you'll set up a camera to take photos to
make sure their parents aren't sticking
into the rooms when they're in class so
like that's a really fun project that
uses code and sensors and other
engineering altogether and a lot of
these projects aren't even that
difficult that sounds incredible I am
really jealous of the kids these day in
this hobby have you know that you know
somebody at your home isn't in your room
right now going through your stuff yeah
that's all you have to build something
like this yeah I love it I love it yeah
I just started picking up some nests and
the nest protects and I love the way
that it interacts with me in my home
environment and so I would love for our
students out there to be able to create
these types of things for their own home
like home automation why don't you yeah
why just go and do that so thank you so
much for joining us we've learned so
much today yeah and I guess before we
sign off do you want to tell us a little
bit about where you are right now what's
behind you
um right now I'm at the Adafruit Factory
just why it's kind of loud and like
crazy over here and we're in the middle
of the busiest season Christmas which is
when a lot of parents and get suffered
their kids a lot of sisters and brothers
get stuff for their siblings and cetera
and people get some for their parents or
significant other so people are giving
the gift of learning electronics this
season and so we're really really busy
and that's why there's so much stuff
going on here but it's also really
exciting to have a factory here and yeah
and you make a lot of your own
components that go into your kits you
make them in-house right yeah a lot of
these technologies you know it's not
stuff that's necessarily available to
people who just want to like play with
sensors or LEDs or other electronic
components so we do is we make breakout
boards or design kits and we contact
factories and we can purchase like large
quantities and get custom-made stuff
like displays made for us and then
provide them to customers so we kind of
get to go to all the factories that make
cell phones and say hey we're not making
a cell phone but give us all the stuff
that you can make your own cell phone
and that's what we have an Adafruit shop
beautiful well thank you so much for
sharing your your factory and your time
today really appreciate it and if you'd
like to learn more about l'amour and
three industries go to Adafruit
Industries or adafruit.com right that's
right cool tech oh awesome thank you so
much l'amour okay thanks make sure to
join in on the fun @ CS ed week org
where you can participate in an hour of
code during computer science education
week